what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with another installment
of our beyond omega level series where
we break down the most powerful
characters in comics and this week we're
going to talk about a character that was
suggested by one of our viewers taiwan
1984 who suggested that we cover hunger
the devourer of realities now this is a
character that was created by jim
starlin and first appeared in thanos
number one in 2003 so this story
basically opens up with thanos just kind
of sitting alone honestly kind of moping
around and he's visited by adam warlock
who has tracked him to this location and
is concerned that he's going to destroy
the nearby planet of rigel 3 home to a
race known as the rajelians who are a
really cool race actually they created
the recorders but to warlock surprise
however thanos seems to have turned over
a new leaf and is actually there to make
amends and help the regellians with
whatever it is they need because he
terrorized them in the past so thanos
and warlock go to the regellian planet
and learn that there is something the
regellians need help with on another one
of the planets they've colonized rigel
18. now when they arrive they find that
the planet faces a major potential
catastrophe as galactus ship has been
parked nearby indicating that he isn't
planning on consuming the world because
if he were he would have just already
done so all the while we also see panels
depicting a pair of glowing eyes
commenting that everything is going
according to plan so after thanos tries
and fails to learn galactus plans by
meeting with him telepathically galactus
puts his plan into action he uses his
technology not to consume rigel 18 but
to cause its sun to explode now galactus
then ventures into the dying star where
a portal to another reality has
basically formed and so galactus reaches
in and pulls out a skeleton with a
purple gem on its chest then the
disembodied glowing eyes we saw earlier
break the fourth wall and begin speaking
directly to us as the reader so what
ends up happening is this thing
basically introduces itself as hunger
and discloses that it has recently
become aware of the existence of the
main marvel universe when it observed
the energy produced during the infinity
gauntlet saga now because the energy
burst was brief hunger was only alerted
to the existence of the universe but
could not pinpoint its location so it
waited until magus the evil aspect of
adam warlock united the infinity gems
when it learned the location of this
universe of course that happened during
the events of infinity war however
because the universe was spherical
hunger could not enter it on his own but
needed an unwitting accomplice with
sufficient power and an exploitable
weakness in order to help it so
basically hunger tricks galactus into
thinking the vibrational patterns of the
infinity gems were identical to those of
the living energy he needed to survive
and so galactus then constructs a device
which he thinks will siphon energy off
of the infinity gems which will allow
him to stop consuming populated worlds
because it's one of the things that he
hates he hates consuming worlds but the
true purpose of the device is to open a
portal to allow hunger into the marvel
universe because hunger is like galactus
in that it is a devourer but while
galactus devours planets hunger devours
reality so think of hunger as a less
interesting version of the black winter
from donny kate's thor run but hunger
doesn't divulge anything about its
origin it does however reveal its
motivation for coming to the main marvel
universe while also saying that his plan
to devour the universe simply cannot be
stopped and so when galactus finally
gathers the infinity gems and then opens
the portal he's shocked when it does not
unlock a limitless energy source but
instead grants hunger entry into the
universe now galactus summons all of his
power and blasts hunger but hunger
simply consumes it as nourishment he
quite literally eats the power cosmic
and so it's clear from this altercation
that even the combined forces of thanos
and galactus are vastly overpowered by
hunger and it's only because thanos has
devised a clever scheme to transport the
old rigel 3 to impact rigel 18 and place
the nuclear warhead at the detonation
point that they're able to gain a
victory over hunger however after the
explosion we see hunger has survived and
then flies off into space seemingly
setting up a return now the return
wouldn't come until 2018's thanos the
infinity siblings graphic novel which
explains that hunger spent eons floating
through space basically being a shell of
its former self then it encounters a
planet full of beings it could absorb
and steadily increased in power until it
was able to kill a version of thanos
that is vastly more powerful than the
last time they fought however thanos is
able to travel to a point in time
centuries before that happens and kill
hunger before he's able to regain his
power now it would be revealed in 2019's
the infinity ending that it was actually
adam warlock who used the soul gem to
give hunger a boost of power that he
needed to conquer the planet zeltya
which led him to being able to defeat
the nearly omnipotent version of thanos
that he defeated in the infinity
siblings and of course we haven't really
seen hunger make an appearance since
then and who knows when or if jim
starlin will ever go back and work with
marvel again as the infinity ending was
billed as the last chapter of the thanos
story that he'd been telling for decades
so we really have no idea if we'll ever
see hunger again in a marvel comic book
at this point it seems unlikely and in
all honesty it's not the biggest loss
but just to recap this guy's powers he
literally consumes entire realities i
mean he's like galactus but just one
step higher on the food chain and his
devouring of realities makes galactus
devouring of planets seem like child's
play hunger also has very powerful
telepathic abilities as evidenced by the
fact that he was able to take a being as
powerful as galactus and basically use
him as an unwitting pawn to do his
bidding without having a clue that he
was being manipulated and galactus is a
being that has cosmic awareness and so
the fact that hunger made him its puppet
from a completely different reality is
pretty freaking impressive now hunger
also states that he can effortlessly
travel between parallel dimensions and
only has difficulty with spherical
dimensions like the main marvel universe
and there appears to be no limit to
hunger's potential power level as he was
able to become so powerful by infecting
and absorbing other beings that he took
down a nearly omnipotent version of
thanos and that's basically all there is
to know about the character he hasn't
really appear very often and like i said
i doubt he'll show up anytime soon for a
character as powerful as he is he's
pretty cartoonish which might be why he
hasn't really caught on outside of jim
starlin's books but i do like to fulfill
fan requests from time to time so leave
them in the comments if you have any
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace